so
bill maher says why mass shootings
happen four reasons mental health easy
access smartphones movies and tv right
and he spends a lot of time talking
about movie tvs and video games
specifically movies where it's like the
shoot the heroes the what and he talks
about all these movies that are about
revenge revenge revenge revenge he gives
50 movie titles that have vengeance in
them revenge right
and the bad guys always get slaughtered
by a automatic weapon the good guy only
gets hit in the shoulder and you put a
band-aid on it and it's good to go on
your safe right okay so then stats comes
out
and it says
22 weeks into the year
america has already seen
246
mass shootings
so my wife is sitting there she's like
babe is it kind of weird that all these
mass shootings are happening
so let me read this article from npr and
by the way npr is a we know who npr is
it's a very liberal tax funded media
company may 14th a racist attack at a
buffalo new york supermarket snatched
the lives of 10 people and three
more injured it was the deadliest mass
shooting of the year in the united
states for just over a week ten days
later gutman targeted a fourth grade
class at an elementary school in uvalde
texas killing 21 and during injuring 17
it was the deadliest school shooting in
america since sandy hook okay mass
shooting happened in the u.s with
depressing uh regulatory among the at
least 11 mass shootings over the first
weekend and june 14th uh june 14 people
were shot near a nightclub in
chattanooga tennessee 14 people were
shot in a busy entertainment district in
philadelphia and eight were shot at
graduation party in summertown somerton
south carolina it follows a shooting at
a hospital in tussle oklahoma tulsa
oklahoma and the weekend of violence the
previous week sunday is day 156 of the
year the country has already experienced
at least 246 mass shootings so far at
least 246 in just 22 weeks the average
out to be 11 a week the tally comes over
the gun violence archive the independent
data collection organization etc etc
right let's talk about okay
so
here's what i thought about i said
whatever we see we want to become
why do so many kids become athletes
because that's what we watch
if sports wasn't on tv
would kids become professional athletes
or would they just do it for
entertainment if if we didn't have
a
you know a
tv to watch michael play like mike
i want to be like mike right or mark
maguire baseball derby with you know
sammy sosa or barry bonds or wayne
gretzky or roger clements or you know
thurman thomas or barry sanders or
emmett smith or bring it to today you
know judge yeah all the aaron judge
who's just killing it on track to he
wants his 400 million dollar contract so
all these things you're saying i want to
be like that guy one day i want to be
like that guy one day why because it's
repetitive and we turn him into heroes
and it's repetitive okay
every
time i turn to
anything on the news another mass
shooting another mass shooting another
mass shooting another mass shooting
another mass shooting another mass
shooting
it's a form of recognition
and it's constant recognition
recognition recognition then anger anger
anger anger recognition recognition
recognition anger anger anger anger
anger
so kid is sitting there who's already
angry
at a video game he played girl that
broke up with him
whatever he's going through mom didn't
tell him he's lo he loves him being bad
he left him being bullied in school
which is happening left and right
all this stuff is going on he's saying
you know what it's not fair
it's not fair and he goes out there and
does something
so
to everybody that's kind of like
wondering maybe i'm not alone on this
are you also wondering why we're having
so many mass shootings is this almost
needed for them to say see we need guns
you see we need guns you see we need
guns you see we need guns
my concern is who are we recognizing
who we recognizing
and are we wanting these people also
become heroes and kids are like i'm
going to go be a hero dude you're not
becoming a hero
by doing what you're doing you're
ruining your life
by doing this
there's no benefit to you doing this
part but
and then the other side becomes with the
media smartphones easy access mental
health okay mental health
partially that's on
these pharmaceutical companies you got
the video games they can talk about
nobody wants to talk about hip hop rap i
grew up listening to a pop rap hit em up
all this stuff dmx all this stuff it's a
lot of anger it's a lot of hatred oh
can't believe you're doing that you're
becoming like this one no i'm not i'm
just telling you affirmations has power
right
but there's a form of recognition people
want to be stars today and this is an
opportunity for me to get my you know 15
seconds of fame or whatever it is right
but why do you think we're having such a
surge
in mass shootings right now 246 for the
year and it's only june why do you think
we're having such a surge of mass
shooting
hey are you
well look i i you i did see that thing
with bill maher by the way bill maher's
probably one of the more reasonable
necessary voices in america today
because he's not just calling out again
this goes back to my initial point when
trump's not there you don't have the
scapegoat anymore you have to call out
real issues
but the gun situation to your point it's
not just one thing it is mental health
michael touched on it i don't think 18
year old kids should just go in there no
background check boom they have a gun i
think it should be raised to 21. i think
when you're 16 17 18 you're in the
middle of high school you can't get laid
girls won't pay attention to you you're
bullied you're picked on you're watching
movies all these movies that you're
playing games call of duty this that
there's so social media bullying there's
so much stuff happening to you when
you're 16 17 18 your body's going
through different things transition
and you're angry you're [ __ ] pissed
at the world you know i remember being a
16 year old kid 18 year old kid i would
fight with my parents every day you're
just you're in such a negative state of
mind it's a toxic environment and now
you have access to a gun
i'm sorry i mean things need to be done
we talked about um
the easy access to guns but mental
health look do you think people in the
united states are crazier than
everywhere else in the world
i think we have an equal amount of crazy
people in the united states as we do in
europe as they do in australia as they
do in canada crazy is crazy i don't
think usa is crazier but when you
add on everything else you touched on
with on top of mental health it's a
recipe for disaster and it's
look at the end of the day
enough's enough but why increase in mass
shooting i don't know if there is i mean
maybe there but i just feel like the
media sensationalizes everything i think
it people are
completely within their right to be fed
up with media and media
you know whether it's trump whether it's
mass shootings whether it's politics
whether it's any like they're gonna
cover the event that gets eyeballs
so me you know as sad as it is
people tune in to you all day two people
tune in to what's going on in buffalo
people tune into when a synagogue gets
shot up people tune in to when
someone walks into a church start
shooting up church goers it's horrible
but the media goes by eyeballs and like
you said affirmation has power and what
you show on the media is a real thing so
i don't know if there's more mass
shootings now or if they're just
covering it more i know you just said
the stats but
something needs to get done and this is
the first step in the strategy that what
the what the senators are doing and keep
in mind it takes
in the house i think it's just a
majority vote
and then the senate i think you need 60
votes so we're not even anywhere close
yet but i think the country is yearning
to do freaking something to sit back and
be like hey a good guy with a gun stops
a bad guy a gun well it didn't really
work in your ball day did it because the
[ __ ] cop stood outside the classroom
for what 45 minutes
good guy with a gun but but that but
then but that doesn't
fix it the the the changes they make
doesn't fix that
not everything
not everything is going to fix an
individual scenario but i think we're
talking in a macro perspective for the
united states right things need to get
done you touch on opioids mental health
is a major thing okay
like you said rap hip-hop to an even
larger extent
the the video game gun culture movies
you know the good guy like you said the
bad guy gets his head blown off the good
guy gets shot in the shoulder keeps
carrying on
all these things add up to what's going
on in america today i'm going to tell
you why i don't think it can be fixed
and it's because of the mindset of the
country right now and i'll give you my
experience i spent eight years in prison
and during those years i spoke to a lot
of young kids that came into the system
21 22 years old mandatory minimum drug
sentences they get 20 years they're
spending 17 and a half because no more
parole in the federal system
you can write the same script for every
single one of them fatherless home
mom young trying to do her best she's
got her own problems can't raise the kid
properly he's got no guidance gets on
the street you know gets with the local
bank gangbanger drug dealer before you
know it they're in prison no guidance
whatsoever right
and that's the trend give these kids
contraceptives when they're you know in
in high school let them go out and have
sex all they want so they can bring kids
into this world
that don't have a father and don't have
a stable home
now now they have their cell phones i
agree with bill moore you can get
netflix on your cell phone now it's not
like you have to go to movies anymore
what do you go look at netflix action
adventures shoot em up shoot em up shoot
em up all low budget films all about
action and adventure that's what these
kids are watching it's all about guns
guns guns guns that's the kind of
product that they're putting out there
now especially after the pandemic so
they're seeing all of this stuff they
got no guidance in the house nothing at
home
emotional problems yeah because so many
of them are on drugs that brings you an
emotional issue right away you're not in
your right mind when you're doing this
stuff it's a deadly lethal com a
combination of things that are taking
place and there's no cure at this moment
because nobody's willing to go back now
i i will offend people i don't know why
women are offended when you tell them
your child doesn't have a father why is
that offensive to you ladies do you want
to bring this kid up by yourself you
don't want help
i'm a father i want all the help i can
get with my kids you know and the right
kind of help i want my wife there when i
can't perform she can when i can't
reason with them she can but people get
offended by this now you're offending
women if you say you know you should
have two parents in the home so how is
this going to turn around
i don't think it is
i i know it sounds like i have a
pessimistic view because i'm being
realistic this has been my experience
and i i don't
you know unfortunately in life so often
i mean it happened in me i had to i had
to sink to the depths before i made a
transformation in my life you know i had
it had to hit me because at one point
time i thought i was in control i
thought i can do everything until boom
you know i'm in a 6x8 cell thinking i'm
going to spend the rest of my life there
and then wow this is a real problem i'm
in trouble here and i started to look
like like patrick said then you start to
really look at things what's going on
here for me fortunately it wasn't too
late so
what's going to happen here before
people say okay enough we got to get
back to reality you know i'll tell you
this too and this shouldn't be offensive
as a matter of faith you can't push god
you can't push god out of everything
you know you can't unless you unless you
have a clear answer as to why we're here
and there is no god you have to at least
consider him you can't push him out of
everything and that's happening here in
this there's no alternative what's the
alternative a real documented evidence
backed alternative to god give it to me
and then maybe we can look that way but
there is none so people are pushing god
out
and and it's showing
and listen as a christian i'm telling
you it's biblical it's prophetic you
know you don't you don't want to i don't
want to get there right now because i
don't think this is the appropriate time
for it but i see what's happening but
michael maybe
what you said is very powerful and i'll
tell you why like what what hit me
is maybe your story is a metaphor of
what needs to happen to america because
you said you know you were gangster
you're a racketeer you ended up in jail
for eight years could have been longer
you had to look at yourself in the
mirror and say am i going to spend the
rest of my life in this cell and you had
to hit rock bottom before you had to
turn your life around which you have
rightfully so i know but maybe that's
what needs to happen to america right
what would that be animal what what
catastrophic thing would happen to would
have to happen to this country till we
say wait a second
we need
we got to go back to the roots we have
to have a family here i think it's a
culmination of everything that's
happening right now okay our kids are
being killed off in drugs exactly
in droves this is this is you know what
i think it's the worst problem we're
facing in this country it's an epidemic
and people are not paying attention to
it those that are suffering over it and
there's so many of them if you think a
hundred thousand kids a hundred thousand
people between the ages of 24 and 45 how
many families has that affected
100 000 yeah
we're talking a lot of people are
affected by this and it hasn't stopped
it's continuing it's probably getting
worse
so what catastrophic event has to happen
before we realize hey this is real
problem here
how do you reverse that i don't have the
answer i don't know
because the mentality now that's why i
get so incensed with people on the left
you see this stuff happening
you're pandering to criminals you're at
the expense of legitimate hard-working
citizens
you're doing all these things that it
you know bible says there's going to be
a time when good is bad and bad is good
it's happening right now
and i don't know how you reverse that
but i think
at the end of the day common sense needs
to win out i mean everything you touched
you talked about is absolutely accurate
and i don't have kids so i'm not i don't
have those same exact worries that pat
has every single day with a one-year-old
a five-year-old
eight-year-old and ten-year-old right i
mean i don't have those exact same words
it's scary out there but still i'm sure
pat would would agree that the future
does look bright but sometimes it
becomes you know what is it it gets
darker before it becomes light i think
we're going through a very dark time in
america right now and i think it's going
to get uglier i think a recession as pat
talks about is upon us but
you know
mcconnell nancy pelosi the you know the
the
octogenarians out there the
80-somethings are also running this
country i think it's time for them to go
and i think a new leadership needs to
take place that's why i'm so excited to
vote for someone like a ron desantis i
think a new fresh perspective needs to
reach america the same old same old that
we've been doing for decades
is not going to work anymore but here's
my thinking and patrick maybe you can
because i know how you think and you too
adam
what kind of catastrophic event has to
occur
before we get back to the roots of what
we're really supposed to live like we're
parents you'll you'll experience maybe
this one day
we understand what it takes to raise
kids it's not easy it's difficult even
under the best of conditions it's a hard
job it's work and we're raising a person
to go out into the world look you know
i'm a fr i will not allow my daughter to
go into los angeles alone so you can't
go
dad you can't go period i am not going
to have you there worrying that you're
going to get out of the car or you're in
a parking lot and somebody is scoping
you out i tell you you got pepper spray
you walk into a parking lot you do what
i do okay you look all around you you
make sure everything you know you know
everything around you she's dead you're
getting me nervous so i want you nervous
because these things are happening right
now and i don't want you to be that
statistic and i don't want to go through
that i'm being selfish too because she
listens to you well she does because i i
put fear in her in that way i said look
this is the world we live in you know
it's reality
okay you go out you're in a parking lot
i'm hearing i mean
in new york they're going up to people
and throwing them on their tracks
i lived in that city i never saw things
like that
i mean this is a crazy even crime riddle
new york in the late 70s early 80s yeah
in the 70s it was pretty bad back then
right it was someone like giuliani had
to come in to clean it up it was well it
was very bad back then yes
honestly and you know what people can
say what they want about giuliani he
prosecuted me wanted to put me away for
the rest of my life and i liked the guy
because he cleaned up my city
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]